okay so I'm being a realist the trailers
for war for the Planet of the Apes don't
actually show you the meat of what this
movie is about weird ending is awesome
out of respect for that I'm not going to
actually tell you the meat of the plot
points of this moon experience it for
yourself
because it's worth it
[Music]
war for the planet of the eight the war
for the Planet of the Apes is the third
installment of this new wave of Planet
of the Apes movie started with Rise of
the Planet of the Apes then with dawn of
the Planet of the Apes which one could
argue dung comes before rising but
whatever after the events of the last
film we found out this army is coming
for the Apes now they have arrived in
comes Woody Harrelson and the last best
hope of humanity so he sees it which
brings Caesar to some very tough deep
emotional spots in life enters the war
for the planet I guess I gotta get that
as a way right now war is not the title
I would have chosen to describe this
movie battle for the Planet of the Apes
maybe although that is actually another
movie this isn't a remake of that
conflicts over the Planet of the Apes I
guess not war or for the Planet of the
Apes sounds like if you're looking for
this movie on whatever streaming service
you use you're going to find it in the
action section this movie is actually a
thinking movie it's a very emotional
movie it's a drama I just feel like some
people are going to go into this movie
thinking oh let's watch an action film
and they're not really going to get that
I don't want that to put people off in
the movie managing expectations what I
do here all right first of all the
special effects this movie is a
technological marvel the Apes have never
looked more real Andy Serkis what is
there to say does he deserve an Oscar
probably will he get it probably not but
he's so good in this smoof if you're
just an odd how lifelike these talking
apes look and act in these films this
more so because it's been a couple years
technology advances a lot in a couple of
years this really really is Caesars
emotional journey you are there with
them and seizures just dude he's had it
man he never asked for this word ever
asked for this conflict but he's in it
he's just like someone [ __ ] on this
front porch is like I got to deal with
that what I love about Donna the Planet
of the Apes and war for the Planet of
the Apes is the fact that he's always
really are a mirror on humanity using
aids in the last movie were like all the
Apes are the good guys in the humans are
the bad guys but we saw good humans on
the human side and bad apes on the ape
side you see Koba did what he did in
dawn of the Planet of the Apes out of
fear and hatred and nothing good ever
happens out of acting out of fear and
hatred and then you see Woody Harrelson
in this movie war for the Planet of the
Apes acting out of fear and that's a
great thing about this movies the human
beings feel desperate they're like if we
don't act our species is going to go
extinct I've never been in that
situation I've never pondered that what
I do in that situation I don't know if
you're really faced with that dilemma
I'm sure you would do some door
- that's the thing this movie forces you
to ask what would you do in woody
harrelson situation what would you do in
Caesar situations Caesar because it's
like you know Oh Hail Caesar is the
greatest leader ever he is eight Jesus
if not a peon Connor
but even your heroes are flawed and this
movie Caesar has some flawed moments but
you understand them by flawed moments
that's no judgement I'd probably do the
same thing you did which means we're
just all a bunch of flawed beings trying
to just scamper our way through this
thing we call life no one has the
answers and this is just more to the
point is the fact that Caesar is such a
character the only way I can describe
him is he is so human though we would
probably take it as an insult dawn of
the Planet of the Apes moved more than
this movie I'll say that Donner the
Planet of the Apes was a really good mix
of action meets drama this leans more on
the drama side than action there is a
little ape in here I think he just calls
himself a date he's the one in the
trailer he's like long time and that
dude could have been annoying right when
I met him in the movie I was like all
right you could be Jar Jar Binks you
could be better
turns out he's better the title just
goes on just to cracked me up and it
answers one of the questions you have
are all those smart Apes with Caesar are
there other Apes out there he didn't
start out with visas they're like oh
they're okay there are other Apes out
there I like that dude I was surprised
that I did and I really did there are a
lot less humans in this movie this is
really Apes n trick here which doesn't
matter and it doesn't bother me because
the Apes are clearly fleshed out
character you're not there with the CGI
husks going okay where are the real
people the entire time of the Apes
you're like those are the real people
it's in the end war for the Planet of
the Apes floored me I really enjoyed it
when I walked out of it and it's gotten
better as I have slept on it as I
thought about it it's not as action
centric as the title would have you
believe when the action at the end goes
down it's entertaining enough but it's
definitely not the point like it will
take a break from the action to turn on
the drama give you a moment this movie
has a lot of moments man when this movie
wants to tighten the emotional guitar
strings there you are you're like good
and it does it effectively but this is
Cesar's greatest trial today and I will
say war for the Planet of the Apes is
awesome tacular
and yes this review is up early I get
that and thank you for watching I'll
have my spoiler talk where I can go more
indefinitely okay here's some spoilers
here's what happen in the movie
specifically I thought we find a deal
I'll have that out when the movie comes
out so war for the Planet of the Apes
are you going to see it what are you
hoping for whatever you're hoping
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]